So reflection is at the heart of some of the functionality we just talked about for anyone who's not familiar with the term reflection
You might be familiar with it if you're used to something like C sharp. It's codes ability to examine itself
C++ doesn't have any reflection capability at the moment
I know there's some discussion about reflection getting added in the C++ 26 standard or something like that
I'm not completely certain about that
But for now unreal has a reflection system that it implements itself and that all stems from the U object
So U object is unreal's kind of base type for anything that is really
In relation to the engine and gameplay functionality U object is kind of base the start of anything that can be reflected comes from
U object any game object any bullet visual effect sound cue anything in the class hierarchy
It all comes from U object as the base
It's important noting that get U objects anything that extends from U downwards is only accessible on the game thread
Their memory is automatically handled by unreal which implements garbage collection and U objects
Support serialization and all that means for saving and networking and all stuff like that
So it's important to highlight that the U in U object is actually important
Unreal has kind of a strong and strict naming convention where if you try a break this you will actually get compiler errors
Anything that is a just a raw object. It starts with U. So
Any kind of anything that is just data is a U object as soon as something
Exists in the world and has a position and can run around and do things
It's an actor actor inherits from U object and at that point we start using the a letter
So all your classes would start with you know a
my snazzy car
That's only in the C++ itself in the actual solution Explorer. It would still be just called classy car or whatever
structs and non U object classes have the prefix of F
Enums have the prefix of E and any templated types
Using generics start with T. So and again
This is a strong convention that you'll get compiler errors about if you don't pay attention to it
The other thing about when introducing a class that uses this reflection system. There's a couple of things you need to do
First off and in going chronological all the top to bottom of the file is you would need a generated H include
so if you look at any class inside unreal, you'll see
There'll be a generated H include if it's a kind of reflected class type
But also it's important to highlight that this include will normally complain at you if it's not the last
Include in your include list. So if we just quickly jump to some code we would see this in
Whenever you make a game mode, you'd see it here
We've got this is a whenever you create an unreal project. Typically it creates a game mode class for you
So it comes I haven't written this is get automatically generated and you can see it's got some simple includes and then it's got this
Generated include itself
We'd also have some kind of reflection markup. So if it's a class then it would be headed with a u-class markup
Macro, if it's a struct it would have u-struct above it
And if it's an enum it would have you enum the last thing
For u-class and u-struct is it would have generated body
So you'd see this here any struct that it's headed with u-struct or any class
That's headed with u-class needs a generated body within it. Otherwise again, the compiler will complain at you
It's worth highlighting as well that when creating a new class, you can actually create classes through the editor itself
you don't have to go through the kind of
laborious process of creating a class yourself and
Creating the header and creating the CPP and adding all this boilerplate. The unreal editor can actually create it for you
If you just go to outside of your content your C++ classes
You can add a new class this way or you can do file
This is maybe changed a little bit since
your tools new C++ class and you can create that here if I went to create a new pawn and
Do all that it would give me a bunch of things and if I went to create that
But just give this a second
Okay, we'll probably edit that out. So it's a little bit shorter, but it does did eventually generate the class for me
And you get the other thing to highlight is that when you do classes this way it will actually automatically regenerate your project files
And it'll perform this live coding compile, which is kind of recompiles all that code
So it'll be updated
but if I just quickly jump back to my project you see is asking me to reload and when I do that it's
going to
When I give a visual studio a second and it's finally caught up
you see we've got a new pawn here and
If I open that up
Yeah, you can see it's got all this markup for us
So you can see our porn is called my porn in the actual solution explorer
But once it's within code is referred to as a my porn because porn inherits from actor
It's already got a generated header include. It's already got a u-class markup. It's already got generated body
So it's just worth highlighting that if you go through the editor
It will generate all this boilerplate for you as well as some kind of stub functions
You might typically need like begin play and tick which I'm sure we'll get to in another session
But just to highlight that that's all kind of done for you
If you go through the editor certain IDEs also do provide the functionality to do that within code
So you don't have to have editor open to do that
But otherwise you can just do this from scratch and just add this boilerplate yourself. It just takes a little bit longer
if we just jump to
play the presentation
It's worth highlighting as well that these macros as they provide a lot of it's not just about
Exposing them to the to the unreal reflection system or that is definitely an important part of it
There's a whole suite of different things that we can mark up with these macros
We've got u-property u-functions u-classes u-struct and u-enum and we'll kind of dig into each of these and what they actually mean
First and foremost the most important thing is that u-property you'll see a lot
It's worth highlighting that when we've said that unreal has garbage collection, and it's a memory. It's managed memory
U-property is a key component of that which I'll dig into it a little bit more in a bit
So it's kind of go through these in an order. We'll start off with u-class. So anytime you have a class type that is
Reflected type so anything that is u-object or down will need this u-class markup above it
You can just have u-classes blank, but you can also add in some extra metadata
to provide some extra kind of
Information to the engine about how it might be used in the editor side of things
So you can a typical ones might be blueprint type which would mean that in blueprint code this class can is
Accessible. It's a type that exists is the type that blueprint understands exists
blueprintable would mean that you can make
Blueprints that inherit from this type and then abstract same as C++ abstract
It just means that this class has nothing within it
It's kind of exists as a template to have other classes inherit from it and then implement each of these functions
All of the u-class markup it can be found in object macros and the same is true for all these reflected types
The u-struct, u-property
object.macros.h
Contains the full list of all these definitions. We'll just quickly jump to that to show you
u-property
yeah, so these are all the
Markup for u-properties and the same thing can be found in here for you know classes, structs, etc
So u-properties again, we would add u-property goes above any member variables of either a u-struct or a u-class
It's probably worth iterating this multiple times, but you can't introduce properties with u-property above them. You can't introduce kind of
Editor facing variables if it's not with inside a class or a struct that also is a u-class or a u-struct
So you can't have u-properties inside a non u-class class if that makes sense
So you would typically add it above variables
The important thing to highlight about this is that whenever you have a pointer type the u-property markup is required
to prevent that
What's contained within that variable getting marked for garbage collection?
so if you have an actor variable and you
Or an object variable or something like that and it doesn't have u-property above it
There's a good chance it will get cleaned up by garbage collection
So the u-property is kind of means that this
Pointer type is reference counted and that it won't get cleaned up by garbage collection until there are no
Objects with u-property above it referencing it. So you typical u-property meta markup would be edit anywhere
which essentially means that this
This value is exposed to the editor and can be tweaked either
Play an editor time or it can be tweaked within the editor or within blueprints
Edit defaults only means that this variable is exposed but can only be edited in blueprints in the actual kind of archetype not within
instances within the level
Visible anywhere is pretty self-explanatory just means that you can see this value, but you can't edit it
Replicated means that this is intended for network replication
But it will actually that this work isn't enough on its own. You will need to do some additional
coding to kind of mark up this thing to get passed around the network and
Transient which just means that this property isn't serialized and it will get filled with the zero value at load time
It's worth highlighting as well that when we're talking about pointers, there has been a transition from Unreal 4 to Unreal 5
a lot of the code base you'll still see will have
Pointer types that look a little bit like this
What if I go inside that porn I just quickly created and you would see inside the header if it had a reference to
An actor it might look like this a actor pointer right a standard kind of raw pointer and then it's still absolutely fine
But with Unreal 5 what they introduced was this new type T object pointer
It is the size equivalent of a 64-bit pointer, but it provides kind of a whole set of extra functionality on top
So it's generally advised that whenever you're having a member property
That is a pointer type instead of a so if I had this type as my actor and again that should definitely have
You property above it because otherwise it's gonna get garbage collected
So you might see something like this the kind of encouraged new type is that we use you T
T object pointer like this
It's not required but it is encouraged. It brings a whole suite of other functionality with it though. I'll just go into now
So most importantly it supports lazy load behavior
What that essentially means is that it's going to speed up your editor build times. So this is more about
Improved quality of life in editor than it is really very much to do with runtime performance
So improve its loaded lazy load behavior, which will heat speed up your load times in editor. It supports access tracking
which is
Not only useful but important to bear in mind when you're doing things like a range based loop
It's that because the actual T object pointer itself will now have data inside it
You want to be looping through those as a kind of like on a reference basis, right?
So you want auto ref rather than making copies of your T object pointers
And when passing it round to functions and when returning it from functions
It can just be used as a it can just return a raw pointer
So it won't have a complete knock-on effect across your entire code base. It's you mainly need to be worrying about it in your actual
member variable declarations
It has supports the same prevention of garbage collections like a normal raw pointer again
It will still require this you property mark up above it
and the other thing is it supports cook time dependency tracking which means that they're
essentially
Increases the chance that the cooker keeps a good track of everything that relies on everything else
Yeah, the places you can already see a lot of the engine has actually made use of this
so if we go to the
Sorry using the wrong hotkeys here, but if we went to the actor class so a
actor dot H
Yeah, you can see that a lot of the engines own
Code has already shifted to using T object pointers rather than raw pointers
If you've already got some raw pointers
It is actually worth highlighting that there's a useful tool that can kind of speed up that transition
which is this unreal object pointer tool that lives in
your
Project
In your engine binaries one second if I can just locate that
So if you locate your unreal engine and you go to your binaries folder
Win 64 and you kind of filter for your applications. You'll find it here. It's called
Unreal object pointer tool
So there's a couple of steps to actually using this
If you look up the unreal 5 migration guide it kind of goes into a bit more detail about that
But that can just help you make that transition from kind of raw pointers to T object pointer
So the next type we're going to talk about is the you function
So this is added to any functions that need to be callable in
in blueprints, it's also important to highlight that any time you have a delegate or a
timer
that you kind of or a
I think maybe it's just delegates and timers you will need to add even just a blank
U-function markup above it if you want this to be
Used so it's essentially anything that interfaces the actual engine level and it supports a couple of different
Markup metadata's the most typical one is blueprint callable
Meaning this C++ function can get called by blueprint. If that's not there blueprint won't know that this function exists
Blueprint cosmetic which is essentially saying that this is only relevant to a client-side
This is only kind of a client-side function
The server doesn't need to know about this because it's purely a kind of visual thing
Server and client and net multicast. These are about the way that information is passed around a server
So is this a message that comes from the server and goes to a client?
Is this a function that goes from the client to the server to notify it of something like input and net?
Multicast is a function that comes from the server and goes to all clients
There's a lot more information that goes into that but those are typical ones that you might see
It's also worth highlighting that this you function would be required to allow any any of these functions to be called over a network and
Lastly we have ustruct and uenum. So ustruct is very much like uclass, but rather than for classes. It's for structs
And it is actually required for as I mentioned previously if you have any u properties within a struct
That struct must be a ustruct type and it must therefore have a generated body
line within it
the typical
metadata that you would see above a ustruct is to say that a blueprint type which again is just means that this is a
Struct type that is visible to blueprint. You can pass it around in blueprints
It's also worth a kind of slight discrepancy between uclasses and ustructs is that with a lot of data inside a uclass
Unreal will automatically zero fill all of that data particularly pointer types
The same is not true for ustructs, so it's worth being it is good process anyway to kind of
Use your initializer lists to fill all your variables with the correct default values
But you need to be particularly sensitive of that with ustructs
So you should be you know, no pointer in by default your your pointers
Otherwise, you might end up with some garbage data in there and that's particularly sensitive with ustructs
And then uenums again just above
Enum types worth pointing out that
Unreal currently only supports uint8 enums
So and I believe they need to be enum class types. So a lot of the time you would see
I'm just trying to think of an any enum type off the top of my head
Collision type I think is one collision shape type if
It's used by engine you'll see it's an enum class and inherits from uint8 if if this were a
Class actually the need to be exposed to blueprint that would need to be a uenum
But a uenum would only work if it's an enum class and it inherits from uint8
We can't have 32-bit enums that's not supported by the engine at the moment